[? [PRINTING SOUND] ?]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The Google Maps API team
maintains client libraries
that give you the
power to develop
with confidence that your
app will scale smoothly.
We provide client libraries
for Python, Java, Go,
and now Node.js.
For the links and
some highlights
of how these libraries can help
you, head on over to the post
linked in the description below.
Native Ads helped SmartApps
India grow revenue by 55%.
To learn how, take
a look at the post.
And for more details
on Native Ads,
check out this article on
everything you need to know.
Chrome 54 Beta includes Custom
Elements v1, Broadcast Channel,
media platform
improvements, and more.
Details and links
are on the post.
Service workers
give you the ability
to respond to network requests
made by your web applications,
allowing them to continue
working even while offline.
But they've historically been
tied to a specific origin.
Well, what about foreign fetch?
For a fun article
experimenting with this,
check out the link below.
The Google Cloud
Platform has launched
a bunch of new products
and features recently.
To help you sort
through them, here's
a post highlighting six features
that were designed specifically
to help you save time and money.
We teamed up with Seeed
Studio and BeagleBoard
to bring you the BeagleBone
Green Wireless IoT developer
prototyping kit for the
Google Cloud Platform.
With it, you can get your IoT
project talking to the Cloud
quickly.
More details are on the post.
Please remember to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[TYPING]
[PRINTING SOUND]
[COMPUTER BEEPING]
[TYPING]
[PRINTING SOUND]
[PHONE TONES]